television is great for telling
serialized stories over time but not
every TV series is meant to last none of
the shows on this list made it past a
single season and we still aren't over
it
pulling from their own awkward High
School experiences as newcomers and
Outsiders in small communities David
varicio and Moses Port recalled the
Genesis of their show aliens in America
in an interview with pathios saying we
started talking about politics and the
giant Gap that exists between Americans
and really the rest of the world
specifically the Muslim World airing on
the CW between 2007 and 2008 aliens in
America focuses on social misfit Justin
tolchuk and his wholesome yet quirky
Wisconsin family they've taken a foreign
exchange student from Pakistan for a
culture Clash comedy about peace love
and understanding as the Show's theme
song goes oh well why don't you wear
warmer jacket over that boy blouse of
yours when Scott Patterson who played
patriarch guarantulchuk sat down with
IGN in 2008 he was full of praise for
aliens in America's humor and its
message calling it relevant for the
times and saying the beauty of the show
is that it shows there's ignorance on
both sides critics were fond of it too
even when the ratings didn't back it up
the Boston Herald wrote that aliens in
America is warm funny and smart doesn't
stand a chance that prediction proved
true two years later variety was still
lamenting the show's cancellation with
the success of Star Wars came imitators
hot on its heels hoping to turn their
own space dust into magic in 1978
producer Glenn A Larson tried to launch
his own Space Opera Battlestar Galactica
in an interview with science and fantasy
film Classics magazine Larson described
his approach to the show it's Genesis
it's basically the concept of all the
human cultures in space having evolved
from a mother Planet culture we've got a
truly rare opportunity to really open up
that Frontier and talk about what could
happen out there in space it doesn't
have to be all robots and flying
machines
the mother World Of All Humans
where life began the series takes place
at the end of a long conflict between
humans and cylons robots created by an
extinct reptilian race Humanity rallies
behind the Galactica of Battlestar
worship led by Commander Adama played by
Lauren Green ready
fire things got off to a bumpy start for
the show when the premiere was
interrupted by President Jimmy Carter's
announcement of the Camp David Accords
the good fight for Humanity raged on but
competition from other networks and
constant comparisons of Star Wars did
the show no favors Ron Cowan from the
Statesman Journal wrote a Battlestar
Galactica at the time the opening was
impressive but the show became more a
soap opera than a Space Opera the
writing was on the wall Battlestar
Galactica was taken out of orbit The
Following Season many prefer the highly
acclaimed 2004 reboot but plenty of
viewers still have a soft spot for the
original series
out of all the zany characters Martin
Short has brought to life few have
utilized his talents better than
buttoned up triangle-haired
happy-go-lucky Ed Grimley short debuted
the character at the Second City and
grimly was further developed on SCTV and
Saturday Night Live but short wasn't
interested in playing grimly on the big
screen instead he took Hanna-Barbera up
on an offer to create a Saturday morning
cartoon the completely mental
Misadventures of Ed Grimley the move
made sense because as he told New York's
The Post Star it's a real-life person
acting like an animated character they
modeled the cartoon after the Adventures
of Rocky and Bullwinkle and Friends
making it something both kids and
parents could enjoy short went tall on
Talent bringing Catherine O'Hara Andrea
Martin and Jonathan Winters on board to
amp the absurdity The Following Season
grimly got the ax replaced by fellow
SCTV Alum John Candy's animated show
Camp candy short bemoans the decision in
an interview with the Tampa Tribune
thing it had reviews like we wrote them
ourselves and NBC couldn't take that
show off fast enough they thought it was
too odd if I had done Ed Grimley Boy
Scout leader it would be on today
MC search AKA Michael Barron knows the
thing or two about what it takes to be
respected as a white rapper in 2007 the
former Third Base member hosted ego
trips the white rapper show on VH1 I was
confused when I seen the white rabbits
coming down the block I was wondering
what was going on you know I mean
according to an interview search gave to
The Virginian pilot the competition
series mixed elements of Survivor
hip-hop Jeopardy racial tension
political views and Seinfeld into one 10
hopeful rappers with stage names like
Shamrock just rhyme Persia g-child and
100 Proof lived in the Bronx and battled
for one hundred thousand dollars they
got to work with hip-hop royalty like
Curtis blow Prince Paul cool Keith Grand
Master Flash and House of Pain members
Danny Boy O'Connor and Eric Francis
schroedi AKA Everlast one contestant
John Boy told The Virginian pilot I felt
like the show was rap boot camp it was
really humbling trying to educate us on
where hip-hop came from up search was
hopeful that a second season would get
greenlit but it never materialized
faux comedy duo Ricky Lindholm and Kate
and coochie are better known to fans as
Garfunkel and Oates they're sometimes
referred to as the female Flight of the
Conchords which they don't mind in an
interview with the Tampa Bay Times
Lindholm admitted we describe ourselves
as that because it's an easy way to let
people know if we do they're naughty
sharp tongued brand of musical humor LED
HBO to develop a pilot with them but it
never took flight instead they landed at
IFC with a self-titled show directed and
executive produced by friend Savage we
can't open for our own knockoff that's
like Paul McCartney opening for a
Beatles cover band playing exaggerated
versions of themselves Lindholm and
mikuchi set about trying to make it big
in Hollywood the duo had to tone down
their act to comply with the tb14 raid
mikuchi told under the radar because of
the show's TV 14 a lot of our dirtier
material we were not able to use instead
they poked fun at everything from Sesame
Street and Saved by the Bell to sports
fans and of course themselves joining in
on the fun were the likes of Tig Notaro
Kevin Pollock Weird Al Yankovic Kamal
nanjiani Ben Kingsley and even Rocker
John Oates who told Entertainment Weekly
I thought they were really clever and
funny so did critics the show dropped to
rave reviews in 2014 news of the show's
cancellation after a single season
didn't go down well as one AV club
headline put it IFC stops being cool
cancels Garfunkel and Oates
it's hard to Fathom that The
Honeymooners one of the most iconic
sitcoms of all time lasted just a single
season the show that CBS first beamed
onto black and white TV sets in 1955 set
the standard for television comedy for
decades influencing everything from The
Flintstones to King of Queens the show
originated as a sketch on Jackie
Gleason's variety show Cavalcade of
stars in 1951. the domestic antics of
Gleason's bus driver character Ralph
Kramden followed Gleason to the Jackie
Gleason Show and would eventually become
the basis for a half hour comedy
a mambo I don't
do although The Honeymooners trailed the
Perry Como show in the ratings CBS was
hungry for more alas Gleason turned them
down the star is quoted in William J
weatherby's Jackie Gleason an intimate
portrait of the great one as saying they
wouldn't believe me when I said we
couldn't come up with the same high
quality of scripts for a second year
Ralph how could you do such a thing
[Music]
Gleason explained that he quote wanted
to go out on top The Honeymooners
characters would live on in specials and
variety shows but nothing would compare
to those 39 episodes Gleason was
nominated for an Emmy for his portrayal
of Ralph Kramden in the show did he ever
regret not making more co-star Art
Carney confided to the course gone a
Daily Sun I think Gleason wishes he made
139 of them
one of the best kids game shows ever
made has been mostly forgotten to time
I'm telling ran on Saturday mornings for
a single season between 1987 and 1988
capitalizing on the popularity of
Nickelodeon's Double Dare producer Heim
sabon came up with the idea he told the
Los Angeles Times we were looking for
creative ways to produce something
different for children Saban added that
there was an overabundance of animated
programming and his show was far less
expensive than a cartoon would be the
format was similar to The Newlywed Game
but here it was siblings who'd guessed
how the other would answer a revealing
question the winning pair Advanced to
the final round the pick a prize arcade
host Lori Faso talked about the show
with the Detroit Free Press saying it's
not demeaning to kids it's not
educational but there's no violence in
it and it's not going to hurt kids in
any way there were a couple of celebrity
episodes of I'm telling in one Sean
Aston appeared alongside his brother
other episodes featured then unknown
talents like Paul Walker Lindsay Price
and Giovanni Ribisi if you can find it
you can relive the magic of I'm telling
by scooping up a copy of the board game
importing a beloved British show is
always a risky proposition for every the
office there are dozens of failures but
Arrested Development writer producer
Brad Copeland saw potential in the
raunchy UK comedy the in-betweeners a
show about four teens who aren't as hip
as they'd like to be beginning in 2012
MTV rolled out 12 episodes some directed
by Taiko waititi we're gonna go on up
there and uh we're going to cause some
Havoc critics and fans of the original
weren't willing to give it a chance to
stand on its own and new viewers perhaps
didn't know what to make of it but the
US version produced its own brand of
laughter especially when Zach Pearlman
was involved like the imported skins
before it the in-betweeners Remake never
caught on in America and soon got the ax
Perlman penned a goodbye on Tumblr
saying I'll always be able to look back
at and smile knowing that we did a
fantastic job according to Joe Thomas of
the UK version the American version was
doomed from the start as he explained to
Sunday brunch they couldn't really swear
very much because it was Network TV and
then you couldn't show them drinking and
stuff and that's kind of the whole show
why do you smell like vomit and cheap
alcohol it wasn't cheap I had gold in it
in 2005 the Globe and Mail pointed out
that three major networks would quote
air new dramas about the United States
under attack from outside forces that
fall NBC's effort was surface CBS had
threshold and ABC went with the
unidentified frightening objects of
invasion in an interview with today
Invasion crater Shaun Cassidy called the
show a suspense thriller in the bright
sunlight Invasion takes place in the
Everglades of Florida the story kicks
off after a devastating hurricane when
strange things start to occur left
behind in the destruction and debris are
two Blended families who do everything
they can to stay dry and keep their
bodies from being snatched by the
unknown Menace lurking in the wetlands
William thickner who played the town's
Shifty Sheriff told the Lansing State
Journal that they wanted to end season
one with a Twist the sheriff's wife
who's presumed dead was The Mastermind
all along unfortunately casting took too
long leaving the series with a different
jarring Cliffhanger that never got
resolved despite desperate pleas from
fans who even flew a banner over ABC's
headquarters no one could undo the
cancellation when HBO's acclaimed series
Rome fell after two seasons Scottish
actor Kevin McKidd looked around for a
new project there were plenty of generic
cop dramas but he was taken by the
script for journeyman he told the VC
star I thought it was different and
interesting and really imaginative and
cleverly written that's all you can go
by the 2007 NBC series created by Kevin
Falls centers around the kids Dan Vassar
a San Francisco journalist who travels
back in time to right wrongs for others
while balancing the affections of his
current flame and his former partner who
is presumed dead journeyman was compared
to both The Time Traveler's Wife and
Quantum Leap and Entertainment Weekly
called it the awesome show the whole
world is ignoring even though it's on
right after Heroes lukewarm ratings and
a lengthy writer strike combined to kill
off the series however when asked about
the series sudden Ending by
Entertainment Weekly fall said we do
answer quite a few questions so fans
will get a feeling of closure Falls
admitted to The Hollywood Reporter that
he felt bad about upending the kid's
life uprooting his family and moving
them to the United States however he
added I'm relieved to say it turned into
a pot of gold the next year Kevin
started his first of 10 seasons on
Gray's Anatomy he also learned to surf
when CBS rolled out its unique and
controversial reality series kid nation
in 2007 there were a lot of concerned
parents the only adult to be found in
the ghost town of Bonanza City New
Mexico was host Jonathan karsch who
stood on the sidelines and watched as 40
kids fended for themselves for 40 days
the idea was to form a community without
descending into Lord of the Flies
territory girls and boys of Bonanza City
[Music]
worm over and over again deal with it
even before the show premiered bad press
haunted kid nation largely due to the
agreement parents signed which prevented
them from suing even if their child died
Hollywood Reporter Nikki Fink loudly
pleaded for the network to yank the show
from their slate and advertisers were
initially hesitant to promote their
brands alongside it regardless CBS stood
by Kid Nation defending their care of
the kids and even prepping a second
season the show premiered to 9.4 million
viewers proving popular with youngsters
but the numbers dipped by the end of the
13 episode run and season two never came
to be the great thing about kid nation
is that it pushed its contestants to new
limits executive producer Tom Foreman
told variety the part that was amazing
and controversial and groundbreaking was
the social element and the documentary
element as the kids figured it out many
of the kids have spoken fondly about
their time on the show which is now
looked on as a fascinating TV Relic
the late writing Duo Stan Burns and Mike
marmor wrote for comedy grades like
Milton Burrell Steve Allen the Smothers
Brothers and Carol Burnett but perhaps
their greatest unsung contribution to
television was a show that saw them go
completely ape in an interview with the
Fort Worth Star Telegram murmur recalled
it all started with the Mad idea of
making a comedy spy movie with no people
just chimps we knew nothing about chimps
or even whether such a project was
possible oh I just can't look I can't
believe my eyes with help from animal
trainer Frank in a 10-minute demo film
was made and audiences went absolutely
bananas over it ABC opened their
Saturday morning cages to the concept
that eventually became 1970s the
Lancelot Link Secret Chimp hour the show
centered on the titular chimpanzee and
his colleagues at ape matahari and
Commander Darwin they attempted to
thwart the Monkey Business of chump with
such grasply characters as Baron von
butcher this easy first step in my
brilliant plan to steal and dispose of
the star of Karachi diamond
The Madness of watching these dressed to
the nines chimps Drive Motorcycles ski
and play tennis was interspersed with
small side guys called chimpies groovy
musical interludes by the band The
Evolution Revolution and even some
Looney Tunes shorts while Lancelot Link
technically ran for two seasons the
second was basically a condensed version
of the first the show would find a new
generation of fans when it naturally
followed reruns of the monkeys on Nick
at night in the 1990s
Life's Too Short is a hilarious one
season show from Ricky Gervais and
Steven Merchant in a BBC press release
Gervais described the show saying Life's
Too Short is a naturalist observational
comedy dealing with everyday problems
human foibles and social faux pas but
with a dwarf the lead role is played by
Warwick Davis who's rarely been given
the chance to show off his comedic side
over seven episodes that began airing in
2011 Davis raised his eyebrows and
rolled his eyes alongside Stars such as
Johnny Depp Liam Neeson sting Helena
Bonham Carter and Steve Carell while
being supported in Clueless fashion by
Gervais and Merchant it's just really
hard to opposite this given the way it
looks I mean yeah okay yeah yeah I can't
have his face staring at me either the
comedy was filled with memorable moments
and Gervais had a ball working with
Davis Davis told CNN that others in the
dwarf Community appreciated it saying
they find that this character doesn't
paint a Rosy picture but paints more of
a real picture in a sense you're a dwarf
how can you not know hi ho hi ho Jervis
said a second season was on Deck but it
turned into a special in which Davis was
reunited with his Willow co-star Val
Kilmer in the 1980s NBC Chief Brandon
tartikov was willing to take chances on
shows that were a bit off-kilter while
one of his pet projects Manimal about a
man who turns into animals didn't hit
the mark it didn't deter him from trying
similar things like 1985's Misfits of
science the show followed a crew of
extraordinary people who drove around in
an ice cream truck there was a scientist
a shrinking man an electrically charged
fonz-like guy and a telekinetic teen
Dean Paul Martin and a young Courtney
Cox were in the cast The Gang not only
had to battle dastardly bad guys weekly
but also the ratings superpower that was
Dallas the lackluster special effects
made the show cheesy yet endearing to
Young audiences who embraced it during
its original run the plot seemed crazy
for the time but that was before Marvel
took over Hollywood in a piece about the
show the Salt Lake City Tribune wrote it
was about a bunch of people with
superpowers so maybe it was just ahead
of its time
NBC's outsourced is a TV adaptation of a
feature film which follows a group of
call center workers in India when Ken
kloppis best known for his work on the
office saw the movie he asked the
creators if he could pitch it as a show
he told The Hollywood Reporter my pitch
was very simple whether it's paper
company in Scranton Pennsylvania or a
call center in Mumbai the petty foibles
of office life are Universal clustered
on a night of big NBC comedies alongside
the office 30 Rock and Community
outsourced had a lot to live up to and
while it didn't go down well with many
critics those who liked it raved about
it while some said the show reinforced
negative stereotypes writer girika
lizardi wrote in a Los Angeles Times
op-ed the humor ultimately comes from a
place of affection
Leslie Nielsen's the Naked Gun films are
considered to be some of the greatest
slapstick comedies of all time but many
people don't realize that his detective
character Frank drebin was in a TV show
called police squad first while
promoting the hit movie Airplane comedic
masterminds Jim Abrahams and the Zucker
Brothers watched a police procedural
show and knew immediately that the genre
was ripe for a parody it would have come
earlier but your husband wasn't dead
then ABC gave the concept a six-episode
trial seeing it as a possible
replacement for Mork and Mindy Nielsen
needed little convincing sign-on saying
I would have paid to be in this I'm on
the same wavelength with these guys puns
and double entendras abounded the weekly
guest star was usually killed off in the
opening credits and those who did
survive including Dick Clark Dr Joyce
Brothers and Tommy Lasorda sought
professional advice from an omniscient
shoe shine man named Johnny Johnny yeah
some kids on the show yesterday
mentioned a new kind of music scar
you know anything about it Nielsen told
the Minneapolis Star and Tribune if ever
there was a show that I thought was
going to be a hit this was it people
didn't know how to look at it one person
who did get it was Washington Post
critic Tom shales who called it arguably
the best comedy show of the 1980s
Patrick mcguin made his name starring in
the series Danger Man released in the
U.S as secret agent when he tired of the
show he quit and moved on to what has
become one of the most influential shows
of the 1960s The Prisoner this
fascinating one season British series
follows an unnamed intelligence agent
being held captive in a creepy Village
where's the police station
can I use your phone
the show was a metaphor for a society at
large Magoon said in a 1977 interview
your village may be different from other
people's Villages but we are all
Prisoners the mind-bending series which
launched the catchphrase be seeing you
was shot at the Welsh Seaside it
featured cryptic villagers decked out in
mod Fashions and the creepiest ever use
of a white meteorologist balloon it even
captured the hearts of The Beatles so
much so that they let the show use their
song All You Need Is Love in an episode
George Harrison's son Donnie told wired
it was the only time a Beatles song has
ever been licensed to a TV show
the 2010 Thriller series Rubicon is an
overlooked gem speaking to the Baltimore
Sun writer Henry bromell said that
Rubicon was born out of the belief that
we in the United States could wake up
one day soon and find our democracy gone
not vanquished by an army but by an
almost invisible collusion between
business and government I know I'm not
the only one who feels helpless and
Powerless in the face of this collusion
the show debuted to 2 million viewers
which was a record for AMC at the time
but it was soon eclipsed by a juggernaut
called The Walking Dead the numbers
didn't hold up and on a channel where
Mad Men and Breaking Bad made good
Rubicon became The Walking Dead itself
in an interview with AV club Romell
projected that James badge Dale won't
have to be doing as much starring and
thinking next season but it wasn't meant
to be season 2 never happened and a
great show was lost in 2019 the New York
Times Revisited the show in an article
head line ahead of its time Rubicon
still holds up and vultures Vikram
Murthy agreed in a piece titled the time
is right to ReDiscover Rubicon
fired by the Pirates of the Caribbean
ride at Disneyland the 1982 show
voyagers is a better time traveler named
Phineas bogg played by John Eric Hexum
and wise Beyond his years orphan named
Jeffrey Jones played by Mino paluchi
it's spelled out its premise in its
opening credits we travel through time
to help history along give it a push
where it's needed while the show took
artistic liberties with actual
historical events it was all in the name
of pleasing the target audience pluge
told the Columbia record in this show we
roll up our sleeves dig right in and
become part of History it's every kid's
fantasy to participate in the great
events in time weaving Through the Ages
they cross paths and sometimes swords
with Cleopatra Abraham Lincoln Lawrence
of Arabia Thomas Edison Harry Houdini
Charles Lindbergh Robin Hood and Kubla
Khan The Washington Post hailed voyagers
as a joyride from start to finish and
the Citizen's voice crazed the show for
its attempts both to entertain and
educate our children tragically Hexum
died following an onset incident with a
prop gun in 1984. this meant that a
second season of voyagers could never
happen even if the network had wanted to
make it NBC had already pulled the plug
however on account of the show
struggling to go up against 60 minutes
which aired at the same time voyagers
remains an 80s Time Capsule one that is
definitely worth digging up
[Music]